here's the chamber now well this is
gonna block the outfit we were like we
got to see this outfit you look vibin
thank you so much who are you wearing
tell me about the jacket the why now I'm
wearing some bullsh a & gabbana I have
some nice like they're like white shoes
yeah I've got a movado watch this from
her lakeside if I usually don't wear
watches because my mic wrists are so
tiny dude how would you describe the
look in one word this is amazing um I I
usually don't I usually don't like have
such like sounds like a crazy look like
this you know what the texture I'm
usually not used to it so I think it's
like bougie I guess yeah yes your boys
are wearing Versace Dolce look at you I
love thank you big night this movie has
just got everybody so excited have you
seen all the scenes and do you
understand all the jokes yes I have seen
all the scenes and I do like you
actually understand all the jokes but
back when we were filming I actually
didn't understand like pretty much like
I would say 50% so if I ever didn't
understand anything all I'd have to do
is just ask someone especially my
parents and if my parents felt like I
didn't need to know it yet then I didn't
even know it yet it seems like that was
the rule on set you got to ask mom and
dad yes that's really yeah yeah pretty
much
she has the role in life really say you
got a big birthday coming up you're
gonna be 13 becoming a teenager what are
the plans for the birthday and I gotta
ask you have you talked to mom and dad
about dating when is that going to
become okay probably I don't know I
guess like in a couple years
will she how do you give a turn to be a
teenager you know I'm actually really
it's right about the same time I'm like
oh I I just don't want to be a kid yeah
it's gonna be a different experience you
this movie's huge gotta ask you you
might have another big movie in the
works are you playing flounder or are
you playing flounder you know I do I got
most have heard the rumors yeah it isn't
confirmed yet so you'll have to see if I
mean what kid wouldn't want to be in a
Disney movie yet that would be pretty
cool and are you a Little Mermaid fan I
mean how'd you feel about being in that
one um I mean that would be cool I
remember like watching Blue Mermaid oh
I'm a big fan of like all of his movies
so last quick question for you Seth
Rogen what have you learned from him
about comedy and also do you have a Seth
Rogen impression a lot of people do yeah
well I did learn a lot I learned I
learned a lot about improv like how less
is more like from like as little as like
even a facial expression and I can try a
lap I can try it I'll try oh no you get
you get you get better at it the more
times you hear it you're nailed back
thank you so much